I heard a story I don't know if it's
true cuz I do okay there's a story I
heard that you and Clint Eastwood both
got started around the same time and
that you were both fired from Universal
Pictures on the same day as young guys
getting started out because they found
fault with both of you why would they
fire you Clint Eastwood or you I mean
well
Clint they said you you know you you
talk too slow and your your tooth is
chipped and you won't get it fixed and
you just you don't you don't listen to
anybody you just want to do things your
own way
mm-hmm and I said why are you firing me
and they said you can act that's just
such a crazy story you got it's getting
true in the same day we're walking to
his truck you know afterwards and I said
you know you're in a hell of a lot of
trouble and he said why and I said I can
learn to act you'll never get rid of
that Adam's apple yeah yeah poor guy
poor guy whatever happened
you